we begin this morning with some breaking  news victoria saha going to join us here  live at the scene a shooting that  happened right outside miracle mile  shops there on the strip lots of police  activity this morning  good morning john and heather there's  still some police activity right here by  the miracle mile shop the sidewalk is  closed off there is still some crime  scene tape as police are investigating  we do know that police responded closer  to 3 a.m they did find a man with a  gunshot wound he will be okay but the  suspect was found close by and he was  arrested police say that this was a  completely isolated incident but the  sidewalk here is closed off traffic is  still moving smoothly reporting live  from the strip victoria saha live local  now